what's going on guys this is Rob and now
that we're done with Avengers versus
X-Men versus eternals we will make a
full story out of that video but I want
to try something here I want to cover at
least the first issue of ultimate X-Men
just to see whether or not you guys are
interested in this kind of thing right
so something to understand when the
X-Men are introduced into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe this is likely the
way in which they will be introduced to
the MC right I've been saying for a long
time they've been here the entire time
and that they're just now being
discovered like the X-Men exists
Xavier's out there he's just using his
powers to block everybody's knowledge of
the X-Men's existence but the way this
story opens up is it initially opens up
with the Sentinels immediately going
after and annihilating a cell of mutants
now this is one of the things that's
really interesting about the ultimate
X-Men right this takes place in the
Ultimate Universe so it's not part of
the main Marvel Universe per se but the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is basically
based off the The Ultimate Universe
almost in its entirety this in Earth 98
is pretty much where all this stuff
comes from where all the stuff in the
MCU comes from so one thing to know is
that when it comes to the X-Men in the
Ultimate Universe they were just there
one day we never really got any
explanation at least not immediately in
terms of where they came from how their
powers developed that didn't come until
ultimatum and we'll probably explain
that you know if you guys are interested
in more of this stuff but basically the
X-Men just exists and what had happened
somewhere along the line is that the
Brotherhood of evil mutants had launched
a strike in Washington DC and because
mutants had had striked the US
government so publicly you had a guy
named Bolivar Trask who basically
developed the Sentinel program and a
signal program being used by the
government was literally assigned to
basically travel throughout the United
States to find mutants and then to
either capture them or eradicate them
but to leave leave normal humans
unharmed and in fact Magneto is the one
that leads the Brotherhood of evil
mutants now that's one of the big
differences between Magneto here in in
the Ultimate Universe and Magneto in the
main Marvel Universe one Magneto and the
main Marvel Universe has been around for
an exceedingly long amount of time so
he's been a bad guy at least he started
out as a bad guy he was eventually an
anti-hero and then he became a good guy
and led the X-Men and then went back to
being a bad guy again right he's kind of
been back and forth and back and forth
in the Ultimate Universe there really
are no redeeming qualities when it comes
to Magneto he is a straight up tried and
true villain there's a point in this
story man where he is nuts right it's
it's kind of it's crazy one of the
things that he pulls off but the reality
here is that
myself in the Ultimate Universe which is
to say he believes the Earth should be
inherited and dominated by the mutant
population and that Humanity needs to be
white from the face of the Earth that's
his philosophy and that's it that's one
of the things you guys are going to
notice the the relationships and the
purposes the characters serve are a lot
more simplified in the Ultimate Universe
than they are in the main Marvel
Universe it's nowhere near as
complicated which honestly I think a lot
of you might really really love but
following this kind of message that was
sort of rebroadcast to the world because
people were already aware of it that
what we end up doing is transitioning to
San Diego and picking up with Hank McCoy
also known as Beast now that's one of
the things because the world is aware
that mutants exists they're hated right
everybody hates mutants so as soon as a
human discovers one either they pick a
fight or they try to kill him or
something along those lines in this
instance it's basically a bar fighter at
least a small bar fight that breaks out
between Hank McCoy and another guy now
of course this guy tries to attack him
Hank McCoy overcomes him and sends him
flying into a wall and then he's told to
get out by the bartender before this guy
spreads his brains all over the place
with a shotgun right so ultimately beast
and up leaving that's one of the other
things you guys are going to notice
Marvel doesn't really pull any punches
when it comes to the Ultimate Universe
it's not Punisher MAX dark right but
it's one of those things where it's it's
a lot more realistic and a lot more
gritty in terms of how things are
depicted here which again I think you
guys might also love but in the midst of
all this you basically end up having
Hank McCoy who's met by a girl and when
he's kind of like who in the heck are
you her response is the best thing
that's ever happened right like the best
possibility for you and so at that point
we switch over to Athens Texas now once
they get there of course this girl
basically you know uses her powers which
we can kind of throw it out there now
it's Jean Gray using her telepathy to
manipulate a sheriff in order to have
him take her to where a mutant is being
held only for us to find out that it's
actually storm now the reality here is
that at this point storm is simply just
known as Aurora Monroe she does not
really have her code name yet and that
makes sense because she was always known
as Aurora Monroe like she was just
called Aurora of course this girl
basically reveals my name is Jean Gray
now here's one of the big caveats here
and this is one of the things you guys
are going to notice about the ultimate
universe as well people are not
necessarily as powerful as you're
traditionally used to seeing them being
right so like with Jean Gray and the
main Marvel Universe her telepathy and
telekinesis is on a universal level in
The Ultimate Universe she's not in this
instance she can only control one mind
at a time right she can't really
dominate a room full of Minds at the
same time now of course her powers and
her abilities will progress as time goes
on but in the immediate that's really
what we're looking at here now of course
the other part of this is that storm
doesn't fully know how to use her powers
she's aware that she has them and she
can manipulate weather but she doesn't
have total control over them that's
another big difference as well in the
main Marvel Universe when you first meet
storm she's got total control over her
power she's been using him for a long
long time that's kind of a different
shift with her character that she's a
little less experienced here what we end
up doing is switching over to New York
where you basically have these guys that
are kind of in the middle of a weapons
like an arms deal and they're literally
buying a suitcase nuke uh from what are
basically the Russians now the crazy
thing about this is that in the middle
of all this it's basically an ambush
they take out all the Russians except
for one guy and once they start shooting
him up and the Smoke Clears this guy's
got metal skin obviously this is
Colossus
and it's one of the coolest things right
now the other part about this is that
once Colossus takes these forces out
he's basically dealing with the struggle
in knowing that now that his identity is
public now that people know that he's
Colossus his days are numbered right
because he will be tracked down by the
Sentinels and they will kill him right
ultimately they will there you know when
it comes to the Sentinels themselves
they were designed to be able to counter
virtually any level of superpower now
that again is the thing to understand in
the Ultimate Universe there aren't
really any super high level reality
warpers right so there aren't really any
like molecule men Owen Reese who can
alter reality on a multiversal level or
anything like that it's a lot more
grounded here but of course he's visited
by Jean Gray and Jean Gray is like nope
everything's cool welcome to the X-Men
right like we have a team for you and so
what we end up doing is switching over
to the Xavier Institute for gifted
youngsters and so the X-Men team as it's
being formed here basically is composed
of Cyclops storm Colossus Jean Gray and
Beast now the cool thing about this is
the roster is not complete because they
still have one more guy that they have
to grab crap but the funny thing about
this is that what you end up having is
them basically getting a bit of a tour
of the Xavier Institute now of course as
you guys will notice here there's just
people like there's there's contractors
guys who are hired to paint the place
and to basically make it look nice and
and that kind of a thing right to
basically finish the the place off the
biggest concern that you would have here
is okay if this place is filled with
humans what stops any of them from like
reporting the X-Men to the federal
government well Beast actually asked
that question and then he's actually
greeted by the voice of Professor Xavier
through a telepathic communication where
Xavier says that he's basically
manipulated the minds of these guys so
none of them will ever report any of
that information right like literally he
just uses powers on them which really
kind of shows us that at least in the
Ultimate Universe Xavier's abilities are
comparable to what they are in the main
Marvel Universe he's still exceedingly
powerful but the other part of this and
this is what's really really cool in the
Ultimate Universe the costumes of the
X-Men are more than just ceremonial in
the main Marvel Universe the X-Men have
had a lot of different costumes a lot of
different outfits and in a lot of
different ways Marvel has used those to
either show like a new shift in the
status quo or a new Rider does it to
show that is kind of their take on the
X-Men like when Grant Morrison wrote new
X-Men and gave them basically the kind
of outfits that you see here but in the
Ultimate Universe these outfits serve a
practical purpose that what they do is
they actually cloak the mutant Gene from
Sentinels so Sentinels won't know that
they're mutants as long as they're
wearing these suits under their clothes
they can just walk around out there in
the world and be perfectly fine and
Sentinels will be unable to
differentiate between them and normal
humans now of course once they actually
meet with Professor Xavier and they
start talking to him there is a little
bit of banter back and forth in terms of
you know is this room really considered
a library if it doesn't have any books
and Xavier talking about how he just
reads the minds of his favorite authors
as they write their books and different
things like that right just not
necessarily important but designed to
kind of show us the nature of Xavier
himself but to also present us with what
seems to be a more just kind of calm
down chill instructor kind of guy but
the other thing about this is that we
basically end up getting this sort of
explanation of Xavier and Magneto in the
relationship they have now this is where
things are really really cool and this
is actually a massive differentiation
between the main Marvel Universe and the
Ultimate Universe when it came to Xavier
forming the X-Men here in the Ultimate
Universe the reason he did this is
because at some point along the line he
and Magneto were friends but the
difference in their ideologies is that
Magneto wanted to conquer the world
basically eradicate humanity and only
mutants would inherit it Xavier was a
more practical approach as opposed to
the peaceful coexistence that he's
always espoused in the main Marvel
Universe between humans and mutants
which is what he's striving for here his
immediate reaction to that was no no
matter what war Humanity engages in with
the mutant population it'll be the
eradication of both species right
because for every step that we take
forward humans will become more and more
extreme in an effort to take us out
which means we will have to become as
Extreme as they are and eventually it'll
eradicate all of us at some point along
the line and so because of the
difference in their ideologies Magneto
had actually attacked Xavier and almost
killed him but Xavier basically fled
with Magneto believing he was dead and
when that happened he basically snuck
off here to uh to Westchester and
basically formed the X-Men right and did
it in secret to where basically they
operate behind the scenes and nobody
really knows they're there now kind of
talking about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe here for a second that really
could just be the plot point right that
like Xavier hides the existence of
mutants themselves from the human
population because he knows that humans
will lash out right maybe it's one of
those things where like mutants did
exist maybe not a whole lot of them
Humanity wasn't fully aware of them
maybe it was like a small town here in a
big city there but every time humans
came into contact with mutants they
attacked them and so what Xavier did is
he used his powers to wipe knowledge of
all mutants out of the minds of
everybody across the world so nobody
knows that mutants are individuals that
exist out there so there's no reason for
them to attack them now of course that
also begs a question if that's the case
why hasn't anybody with mutant powers
used their abilities that's that's like
the biggest hole in that theory
you would think somebody somewhere who
was a mutant who would have used their
powers and somebody would have said hey
are you part of the Avengers and they'd
be like no I'm something else you would
have heard about their existence by now
right so my thought in the MCU is that
either is that theory or the reality is
they're just now popping up for whatever
reason why they're literally just now
coming into existence but we don't fully
know why so the thing about this is that
where the questions asked of Xavier like
how is it that he was able to find these
guys in the first place Xavier presents
cerebra now this is kind of a
consistency actually between the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
Universe cerebro for those of you guys
who don't know this is basically
Xavier's computerized device right this
thing that he uses to scan the world
regarding the entirety of the mutant
population as it exists no matter who
has powers whose Powers have fully
developed whose Powers have not fully
developed whether they understand their
abilities or not because remember the
machine detects the mutant Gene and as
long as a person has a gene the machine
will be able to differentiate between a
mutant and a normal human but what
Xavier also says is that in New York
specific out in Times Square that there
is a young kid named Bobby Drake right
who basically fled from his family when
his powers manifested although he
doesn't fully understand how they work
or is even able to control them but he
left his family under the fear of the
fact that the Sentinels would find him
and like his family would be killed in
the crossfire and so at the moment he's
just a homeless kid living on the street
it's a little darker of a take but also
a little more realistic in terms of how
these things would function and so what
ends up happening of course the X-Men
wearing their outfits take to Times
Square and are basically on the hunt for
Bobby Drake now the other part of this
is that there is a bit of a kind of
cloaking device that basically changes
their physical appearances so they don't
necessarily look the way they normally
do so they can kind of go out there they
can operate and nobody will say I've
seen that red-haired girl before she was
in Times Square when things popped off
they don't really have to worry about
that problem the bigger issue here is
that the Sentinels are also looking for
Bobby Drake and they ultimately find him
on a bus now of course Beast ends up
jumping in rescues Bobby Drake but in
blowing his cover now the Sentinels know
that Beast is a is a mutant as well and
so at that point either the X-Men let
Beast die or they jump in to help him
out which means now all their covers are
blown
now this is this again is one of the
cooler aspects of the Ultimate Universe
X-Men because what you end up getting is
Storm basically being asked to use her
powers by Cyclops now one of the things
that I want you to notice here is that
the X-Men are just immediately sent out
into the field by Xavier they're not
really being given any traditional
training that's a big differentiation
because when you first meet the X-Men
and Marvel Comics and like X-Men number
one back in 1963 that like Gene is the
last mutant being brought in to join the
team and she's being given a tour of the
entire Xavier Institute and is being
shown like their training process how
they use their powers that kind of a
thing so like it's a far more organized
system than what seems to be going on
here now again this is only the first
issue so things will change as time goes
on but the reality is that storm using
her powers because she's so
inexperienced she is able to focus her
abilities long enough to take out like
three Sentinels really more two and a
half than anything else but after she
uses her powers she immediately
collapses from The Strain right she just
passes out and so of course that leads
to Beast taking out one of the Sentinels
and so on and so forth and for the most
part like the X-Men basically save the
day now one of the cooler moments here
is that you do have Cyclops who draws
the attention of one of the Sentinels
and when one of those Sentinels snatches
them up and then pulls him over his head
Cyclops just opens his optic beams and
just annihilates this guy but of course
we're one of the other Sentinels kind of
the the one half of one of the other
Sentinels that wasn't completely
destroyed by storm where they make their
move against the X-Men Bobby Drake
unleashes his powers not fully realizing
what he's doing but freezes the whole
thing up right so obviously Bobby Drake
is still Iceman in this universe now I
say that because there are characters in
The Ultimate Universe that are not the
exact version of the character as it
exists in the main Marvel universe so
that's an important distinction to
understand here but a really funny thing
that goes on of course is that as soon
as the X-Men basically you know rescue
Bobby Drake then ultimately they're
immediately attacked by Humanity right
they're immediately attacked by the
people who are there so of course
they're ultimately forced to flee but at
that point we switch to Magneto and the
Savage land and what is going on is
Magneto literally starts talking to like
his Brotherhood of evil mutants in
recognizing that one Professor Xavier is
still alive and two he's formed his own
team which is kind of a counter to the
Brotherhood of evil mutants that can
work to end the efforts of Magneto the
other part of this is that the arms deal
that was going down in Russia when we
initially met Colossus that was being
done by Magneto that that guy Ahmed was
basically hired to buy a suitcase nuke
that could be used by Magneto for some
campaign that he has now we did Cover a
story in the Ultimate Universe called
ultimatum that's basically when Magneto
attacks the world and almost destroys it
I'll have a link to it down in the
description which you're welcome to
check out after this video it's really
really cool but when he gets up here and
he meets with Ahmed then what ends up
happening is of course he you know Ahmed
initially believes it's a chance for him
to explain his Mistake by Magneto and
Magneto's response is no I brought you
here to make an example of you which is
why your henchman or your guys are still
here and he asks him do you still have a
pacemaker and the response of Ahmed is
yes and then Magneto rips the pacemaker
out of his chest using his powers of
magnetism and then tells the Scarlet
which to clean up the mess and then it's
just like we need to find some way to
destroy the X-Men like Magneto's brutal
in the Ultimate Universe man this guy's
nuts and I gotta be honest with you guys
it's the best version of Magneto in
Marvel Comics I'm not even gonna lie the
best version of Magneto in Marvel Comics
is in the Ultimate Universe it's amazing
how cool his character is but the thing
about this is initially quicksilver's
response is okay well I can move with
super speed just tell me where Magneto
and I'll take out I'll take out Xavier
and Magneto's like you're an idiot man
because Xavier would shut your powers
off and probably shut down your brain
before you even got remotely close to
his location what we need is a person
who can sneak in there a person who can
get in there who's basically a master
assassin and so what Magneto does is he
tells Quicksilver go find Wolverine and
tell him that he has a new assignment
Wolverine in the Ultimate Universe man
Sun Sun he's a whole different beast
from the Marvel Universe from Main
Marvel Comics and he's amazing but with
that being said guys we're gonna to
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching let me know if you guys
want to see more of this and I will
catch you all later peace